now governors are telling businesses
when they can reopen but it's up to the
business owner whether to open or not
White House economic advisor Larry
Kudlow says that businesses with the
option to open right now should not be
liable if customers or workers contract
coronavirus after they reopen
let's bring in Andy McCarthy Fox News
contributor and former assistant US
attorney and Andy this caught my eye
yesterday that Larry Kudlow said that of
course representing the White House and
Dan McLaughlin one of your co writers
and colleagues at National Review
basically saying that more lawsuit
protection for these businesses means
faster reopening but that lawmakers
would have to make some of these changes
and I wonder what you think about this
Dana I think that there is a case to be
made for immunity from suit for
businesses especially if we want to
encourage them to reopen I'm very
suspicious of the idea of a sweeping one
and this seems to me to be the sort of
thing
that's why we have congressional
hearings before we do this kind of
legislation no one wants to see the
businesses subjected to frivolous
lawsuits under circumstances where
they're following good business
practices and someone who works for them
contracts the disease on the other hand
I think people would be uncomfortable
with the idea of immunity if a business
were forcing its employees or coercing
them to engage in behaviors that that
were likely to up the spread of the
disease so I think that's all got to be
worked out but I think it's it's the
right thing it's the right direction
it's just you know there's got to be
some limitations on it it's a complex
issue the other issue I wanted to talk
to you about is this idea of the contact
tracing and the surveillance kind of
feeling that it gives to some people
listen to governor Newsom of California
about what he's planning in his state we
in the state of California have a long
history of testing and tracking and
tracing patients the history of TB
measles will get an aggregated data set
that will allow us to track the trackers
and track the tracing
all right Andy I think that this is
well-intentioned but there are some
legal concerns your thoughts yeah
there's a lot of legal concerns with all
of this stuff across the board Dana and
I think we could do a lot better on this
if we just got the burden of proof right
you know if we remembered in every one
of these instances where we have
fundamental rights rubbing up against
something the government's entitled to
regulate like preventing the spread of
infectious disease if we were to
remember that the default condition is
we have our fundamental rights and that
it's the government's burden to show
that a restriction that they want to
impose is rationally related to public
health and is something that needs to be
done in order to to blunt the spread of
the disease yeah I think we'd be in a
lot better shape than what we have now
which is like the assumption by these
governments that their regulation is
what has priority and we all have to
kind of adjust our expectations about
our fund or more fundamental rights to
what they think we know that necessary
or essential yeah we know that the Apple
and Google are working on that app and
that's private sector and is voluntary
but what if your employer requires you
to download the app before you can come
back to work would you have to do it
well that would be a condition of your
employment I think that's very different
than if the government were to coerce
you to do it I think if an employer
wants to require that as a condition
it's a private employer that seems okay
to me what I'd be more concerned about
is the government you know warehousing
this information and using the
surveillance for purposes other than
public health and I think you could be a
swage in a lot of that if you didn't
have governor's saying things like well
gee you know the Bill of Rights is above
my pay grade they may show that they
have our rights yep yep my governor I
think he's doing a very good job but I
just think that was it yeah yeah well
there was a 10-year okay he's doing a
very good job but yeah yep yeah I don't
think it's what he intended
but yes you're right a bad line all
right Andy McCarthy always great to have
you thank you